pero
[Música]
en primer lugar es el aniversario número
15 de iris bangerter como diseñadora en
la pasarela es tan importante para
alguien con tan bellas ideas acabo de
hacer fotos con los fotógrafos no basta
con poner una mano en la cadera y tratar
de quedar lo mejor posible se trata de
crear una historia mientras se hacen
estas fotos aunque estemos tras
bambalinas antes del espectáculo eso es
lo que intenta hacer crear historias a
través del arte es la razón por la que
nos
[Música]
para su colección aniversario de alta
costura de invierno 2022 y desván del
hard pen ha elegido contar su historia a
través de fibras de plátano sedas
organzas recicladas cáscaras de granos
de cacao y estampados en 3-d esto es una
muestra y en cuanto a la inspiración mi
inspiración post humanismo e hiper
realidad
así que realmente nos sumergimos en el
futuro
pero al mismo tiempo me inspiré en las
metamorfosis de ovidio
cuenta la historia de cómo nuestros
cuerpos se transforman en animales o
estructuras vegetales
y es realmente inspirador pensar en la
relevancia que tiene hoy en día
con el emergente metaverso planteando
esta pregunta quiénes somos más allá de
nuestros cuerpos físicos
y esto es realmente relevante de nuevo
porque estamos tocando la hiper realidad
aquí
sí ese fue el punto de partida de esta
colección
quién soy en qué estado me encuentro que
hago en y para este mundo a estas
cuestiones filosóficas el japonés duima
nakazato también tiende un puente entre
el pasado y el futuro la inspiración
para esta colección
los chamanes
técnicas primitivas que mezcló con la
técnica tradicional del quimono japonés
con índigo japonés natural
utilizando la forma rectangular
esto significa que no hay residuos
todo el tejido se utiliza
este es mi mensaje para el futuro del
planeta las mayas es
reflejar dar sentido a las prendas que
diseñamos ese es el verdadero trabajo de
la alta costura el franco camerunés
emaná gis y ha llamado a su colección me
llene esto significa una lengua cuando
de camerún el aspecto
y porque debería el aspecto con la voz
porque para esta colección he colaborado
con un artista camerunés llamado boris
ego
me encanta su trabajo
positiva tiene cierta forma de ver las
cosas en el día a día ha trabajado mucho
con peinados de antaño
con dibujos que recuerdan los peinados
de otro tiempo en áfrica
cuando íbamos a la peluquería siempre
había cuadros con varias cabezas así que
lo retomo a su manera y lo encontré muy
interesante
lo que subraya esta idea del peinado el
lado aéreo el trabajo artístico
lección en cuanto a todo el pelo lo
encontraremos en la forma en que trabaje
las cuerdas que algunas flores y ciertos
bordados
hay cosas que cuelgan o se mueven un
poco cuando las modelos caminan en los
vestidos todo rememora esa idea de la
visión
y man que representa
cierta esencia de áfrica en cualquier
caso un diseñador que se inspira en su
herencia y que mantiene vivo todo el
saber-hacer africano
hay muchos maestros de la civilización
que se han inspirado en nuestra herencia
durante años
hoy en día estamos muy contentos de
contar nuestra historia nosotros mismos
y de forma sublime
es algo maravillosas de la bella
disfrutemos ahora de un desfile sin
música ni sonido de ningún tipo salvas
del fru fru de las telas
adeline andré la más radical de los
diseñadores de moda no se basó en otros
sino en ella misma quería recuperar
cosas que me gustaban que había
abandonado
así que las resucite en diferentes
tejidos así que algunos materiales muy
especiales hay materiales de emín que
obviamente uso muy poco porque éste mi
japonés que se hace con los hilos más
finos del mundo es una tela vaquera de
verdad y es muy fina y eso fue bastante
divertido de usar
por otro lado está la tela de chinon gum
que se llama chirimena que es blanca que
está completamente apoyada y todo eso
que me encanta
que es la seda y por lo demás más bien
algodones y luego lanas cosas más bien
sencillas así no sé qué más podría decir
en realidad
lo que adeline andré podría decir más es
alexander gautier quien lo formula mejor
su moda es decidida
intrínsecamente sexy capaz de satisfacer
necesidades y también deseos
después de todo dar placer a la gente
siempre satisfactorio lo hacemos de
forma muy metódica porque es nuestro
trabajo somos diseñadores hacemos cosas
nos dirigimos a un mercado a una
clientela pero lo más mágico de este
trabajo es verlo brillar en los ojos de
las mujeres
efectivamente qué más puedo decir
[Música]